Ça va? *rires*
On va tourner aujourd'hui un clip qui s'appelle "Placement de produit".
Ça va être génial, et moi je stresse parce que
je vais débuter par une scène assez sensuelle dans une salle de bain.
Je vais devoir enlacer une fille quoi.
C'est pas tous les jours.
C'est cool.
Ça s'est très bien passé,
j'étais très naturel, *rire*
*rire de la femme* j'étais très serein, très spontané
et la sensualité a opéré.
C'est le clip "Overwatch" qui m'a donné envie de refaire un clip en fait tout simplement.
Cette fois, avec Maxenss que j'apprécie énormément, Maxenss fait déjà des clips sur sa chaîne,
qui sont très cool. Il a vraiment un truc , il chante super bien, il a son délire à lui.
Et en fait, quand j'écrivais cette chanson, j'imaginais déjà le faire avec Maxenss.
Donc, j'étais très content, quand il a accepté, qu'il a donné son go.
Ça m'arrive de faire de placer, 'fin... C'est pas du placement de produit , c'est plus des opés, c'est plus pour la sortie d'un jeu, en fait, que je fais ça.
Mais pas de vrais placements de produits, je crois que j'ai jamais fait de vrais placements de produits.
"Ça tourne !"
Là actuellement, j'ai un gratte-dos de la Foir'Fouille.
"Oh oui" : c'est le son que tu fais quand je te gratte.
T'es prêt ? Attention, ça va aller très vite !
Youpiiiiii !!  :)
Ha, non ! Ha, non, non, non, non ! Ça, c'est le gratte-dos de chez Carrefour.
Ha ! M*rde ! Je me disais aussi...
Ha ben non ! C'est celui de la Foir'Fouille !
Ben, si, si ! C'est le mien, là !
Je te laisse celui-là...
C'est un gratte-dos où tu miaules à chaque fois que je te la met...
(combat de pirates spectaculaire)
OOOUUUIIIII !
Moi, ce qui m'énerve, c'est qu'il rigole pas à nos blagues.
Et ce qui est stressant avec lui, c'est qu'il sait qu'il ne doit pas parler.
Il sait que l'on ne doit pas entendre sa voix.
Du coup, c'est hyper stressant, t'as pas de retour, il est juste là comme ça...
*bribes à voix basse*
On va bien sûr faire le bridge, le bridge, c'est quoi ? C'est la révélation où on découvre que notre communauté en a marre de ce qu'on fait.
En a marre des placements de produits.
Et on décide de tout foutre en l'air.
*scène du bridge dans le clip de "PLACEMENTS DE PRODUITS"*
*rires de Squeezie*
OK, on se remet en place.
*scène du bridge dans le clip de "PLACEMENTS DE PRODUITS" jouée une seconde fois*
Et j'ai perdu mes abonnés ! (voix qui mue tel un adolescent)
En fait, on va mettre la musique en fois double, donc à 200.
Pour que, quand on fasse le labial, et ben ensuite,... Oulah, je m'embrouille !
*rires de Squeezie*
C'était beaucoup plus simple de l'expliquer !
En gros, on fait tout en vitesse x2, pour au montage diviser le rush en vitesse par 2...
Ouais, en fait, c'était pas clair non plus !
Ça remet toujours en place !
"Caméra en place"
Tu mets à fond sa mère
A fond les ballons, tu mets à fond les ballons, à fond... à fond les gondoles !
Ça va pas !
Impossible de mesurer son plaisir car il s'agit d'une chose qui n'est pas physiiique !
Ouaaaiiis !
Ça se passe super bien !
On est trop contentes !
On s'apprête a faire la chose la plus cool du clip ; pousser des gens dans l'eau, c'est ça qu'on veut !
*Cris*
(PLOUF)
*Cris* + PLOUF (x2)
Et attention participez à notre jeu concours !
Devinez quelle chanson est en train de jouer Maxenss avec sa gorge !
Envoyez la réponse au 7 800 812 800 912 ! C'est parti !
Nous sommes actuellement en train d'être posé sur Habbo Hotel.
Avec ma gow au tél, plus d'réseau j'ai les pétoches...
Je vais peut-être passer chez...
*léger* Sosh.
Il va parler attention, on va entendre sa voix !
Euh... Sosh !
Ouiiiii ! Il a parlé !
Ouh ! Euh... C'est chaud !
Achetez une chemise samouraï !
Ça donne cette puissance !
Ça me donne la force frère !
Et oui tu le sais !
*Squeezie et Maxenss chantent*
*Maxenss fait du beatbox* (digne d'un beatboxeur professionnel)
Voilà il faut bien rouleauter c'est la base
Nettoyez pas mes chaussettes elles sont dégueulasses
*Baille*, ça me fait p-pleurer, un peu plus.
Voilà... J'suis seul sur ce lit...
Pendant ce tournage...
C'est pas la première fois que je fais un tournage vraiment pro comme ça...
Mais c'est la première fois que je le fais pour un projet à moi...
Enfin, bien sûr c'est pas mon projet à 100% vu que c'est avant tout celui de Lucas et moi.
Euh moi d'habitude, j'prends juste une caméra avec un pote à moi qui m'cadre
Et j'ai juste des idées de lieux, de base, je me fais mon stylisme tout seul
Y'a juste, on part dans la nature, on tourne des plans et c'est pas écrit
y'a rien qui est réalisé à l'avance c'est, non moi c'est vraiment fait à la rache quoi
Donc c'est vrai que ça change
Mais les deux sont autant agréables, j'dirais.
*Squeezie fait de la musique sur le bras de Maxenss*
(voix de Nozman) Expérience incroyable, tendez votre doigt, tendez votre bras au maximum et hop ça fait mal dans le doigt
Ça fait mal dans le doigt, mais j'ai pas mal et là j'ai mal, j'ai pas mal, j'ai mal
C'est énorme.
Eh frère il est arrivé il a dit : t'as un air niai
Bon bah heu..
*rires de Squeezie* oh putain il le fait bien c'est incroyable !
On a réussi ! Oh mais quel KIFF putain !
Et à bientôt pour d'autres aventures incroyables.
"Et c'est une fin de tournage !"
*cris et applaudissements*
- Allez !
- Clap de fin, à bientôt, et merci d'avoir regardé !
Énorme !
Dans deux secondes vous allez plus vous souvenir de rien.. Tschiuu
Sur un making off les gens mettent un pouce bleu.
- Tu crois ?
- Souvent, c'est vrai, j't'assure.
Allez-y mettez un maximum de pouces bleus.
Et on vous grattera le dos toute la journée
- Oh oui !
- Parce qu'avec nous nos douilles, on vous met bien comme le gratte-dos de la Foir'Fouille.